I wake up every morning upset about one
core thing in the context of why we're
all here today from a business
standpoint and that is that that it's
2013 right it's 2013 and 99.9 percent of
the people in this room right now are
marketing their events like it's 2004
the and that to me is it right that to
me is the only reason I've been
successful in my life the reason I was
able to build my family business in a
five-year period from a three to 45
million dollar business is not based on
my good looks or charisma it's based on
the fact that I understood where the
consumer was in 1996 and where they were
more importantly going to be in 1998 I
launched winelibrary.com in 1996 it was
the second wine web site on the Internet
I paid fifteen thousand dollars to build
the website and we sold eight hundred
and twelve dollars in wine in the first
year I don't know how many of you in
this room have a Soviet father but that
did not go over very well
thirty six months later we sold 4.5
million dollars worth of wine that went
over a little bit better and so I think
I think what I'm passionate about is
that we get stuck in the ways we market
direct mail email marketing print radio
television all of which in the last half
decade have collapsed in the attention
of our consumer right when you look at
open rates of email how many people here
have done email marketing for any of
their businesses or what you do for
living raise your hands hide don't
[ __ ] me thank you so most everybody
how many people here have been doing it
for more than five years raise your hand
Howard your email open rates compared to
the way they were five years ago because
there's one thing I know more than
anything more than the fact that I know
that the Sun will come up tomorrow the
thing that I know is that marketers ruin
everything
it's true right how many people here by
show of hands that know half-ass hands
again how many people here signed up for
Groupon LivingSocial daily candy one of
those sites raise your hand
great remember three four years ago how
you couldn't wait to get $40 worth of
sushi for twenty bucks that it was the
greatest thing that ever happened to you
well you don't open those emails anymore
right you don't care if Groupon offers
you a million dollar home for a hundred
bucks you're like delete spam
unsubscribe because they sent you so
much stuff that you didn't want at scale
right and so I mean Google AdWords such
an effective scalable way to market and
and they're down 15% this year I mean
Google is reporting themselves that
clicks on AdWords are down 15% habits
are changing we have to in this room
understand that the only thing you do I
don't care the genre of your conference
I don't care if you're an operator if
you're b2b and trying to get people
whether you're trying to be b2c and get
people to come to the event I want
everybody in this room to understand
including myself whether you sell wine
or or a creative social media agency no
matter what you do there's more than
break no matter what you do every person
in this room is a storyteller it is our
job to tell our story what our value
proposition is to somebody along the
path of purchase period
it connects every one of us and to be a
good storyteller you actually need the
attention of the customer to get an
at-bat to tell your story the attention
of our customers my friends are shifting
and they're shifting fast the eyes and
ears of the people that we're trying to
reach are in a very different place than
they were three four even two years ago
and that is something we have to
reconcile on top of that we have the
respect of how to actually story tell in
those places way too many of you and I
was looking at the hashtag in the tweets
before this event and then kind of try
to look at what you guys did for a
living
to create a little context way too many
of you and I'm talking a staggering 99
percent of you are pushing in your
social channels you're treating the
Facebook's and Twitter's of the world
like it's email marketing you think that
that works you think they're just
pushing come to my event sign up for my
that is bringing absolutely no value to
the end consumer if you do not know how
to provide value in your communication
you have absolutely no shot of
conversion because the world got noisy
right we're following so much more stuff
we're living through the ATD effect of
our society at scale
time and attention is the only valuable
thing in the game right now and you need
to figure out how to break everybody's
culture and tell your actual story how
many people in this room and remember
lying is the devil how many people in
this room five or six years ago said the
following things to themselves or to
somebody else I'm not signing up for
Facebook I'll never have a Facebook
account that's for kids I'll never need
one raise your hand don't lie
raise them thank you how many of those
people that just raised their hands do
have a Facebook account raise them what
everybody in the back just got to see is
what I think about every day which is
that I think about the things that I
know that you're going to do that you
think you're not right now you're
sitting here and you don't think you're
gonna wear Google glasses you're sitting
here right now and you don't think that
you're gonna be on snapchat and I know
you're going to be and so I spend my
time trying to figure out how to tell
stories on those platforms it's what
I've done my whole career and it's what
I absolutely implore you to really think
about here's what I want you to really
stick with if you remember one thing
what you think is socially acceptable or
proper or the way that it should be has
absolutely nothing to do with the way
you should be running your business just
because you don't think it's great that
people are in their phone twenty hours a
day or just because when you go out with
your boyfriend - or husband or wife
spouse - at a dinner and you see a
couple over there and you're like look
how sad that is they're on the phones
the whole time just cuz you believe that
and just because you don't like it and
cuz you're scared that your kids are
watching YouTube for four-and-a-half
hours a day just cuz you don't like that
doesn't mean that that's the way you're
supposed to market your business you're
supposed to flip it understand that's
the reality of the marketplace the
quickest way to go out of business is to
be romantic about how you make your
money and I highly implore all of you to
figure out that it is 2013
if you are not as an event marketer in
full pledge effort of storytelling on
Facebook Twitter Pinterest and Instagram
at this moment you were
borderline not relevant to what's about
to happen in next 24 months that's a
period that's the fact that do you think
your direct mail who here can't wait to
leave this conference run to their
mailbox and open up and go through their
direct mail carefully who here loves
navigating through the internet and
clicking on banner ads we're marketing
in a way that we would never act like
that as a customer but we're just set in
the ways that we've always story told
and how we spend our money email some of
the old-school people how many people
here had email in 1998 1997 just raise
your hands a lot awesome do you guys
remember how we read email back in the
late 90s we loved email there was a
movie called you got mail
right like I mean I remember I remember
sending so many emails in 95 and 6
because I literally thought they would
eventually charge for it
because I was like holy crap I'm never
gonna send a letter which I never have I
mean how is the post office gonna stay
in business they're gonna charge for
this email they're gonna charge for this
stuff that I mean do you remember when
used to get email in late nights you
literally read every word you opened it
went through it carefully I mean this is
what we lived through and so now we just
don't do that now we don't click banner
ads my first banner ad campaign for
anybody anybody here do banner ads in
her career raise your hands just curious
so for the few of you my banner check
this out my banner ad click-through in
1997 was 41% now point zero one is
awesome it's true
it's true now now that we've established
that it's kind of silly that we're
thinking and not realizing that every
time you throw an event you're sitting
with a huge value of content right right
now this is being recorded this is value
you know for biz bash or remember I mean
this chop this up that one three-second
comment I made chop that up and put that
into Facebook because videos over 10
seconds don't work on Facebook or take a
still shot from that last great talk and
put a quote from her and make that a
Pinterest pin that actually gets shared
that links back to these two companies
that's what I'm talking about my friends
how
you actually natively story-tell on the
platforms that people are actually using
and we have to respect the psychology of
why somebody's on Pinterest versus them
being on Facebook see most people the
99% you think of social networks as
distribution for awareness for something
else you think that you're gonna tweet
out a link and you're gonna post a link
on Facebook and it's gonna link back to
your page where you sign them up for
your event right you think of it as
distribution I think of those platforms
as platforms to natively story tell to
bring awareness it is a substantial
difference and what it does is it forces
me to actually bring value on those
channels instead of thinking of them as
impressions that is the shift more
importantly I also realized that social
networks are the first platforms ever
that are actually a two-way conversation
and it's not just push right I mean we
should sell emails too we should sent 4
million emails to wine customers and get
four emails back it wasn't what you did
right we sent you an email
you wouldn't bought the wine now you
send a tweet to ten people for can
possibly return and ask a question about
it it's a far more two-way conversation
Twitter let's talk about it for two
seconds I was looking at a lot of the
accounts that were using the hashtag
were mentioning this event when I looked
at eight different accounts of those
eight people ninety-five percent of the
tweets they've sent in the last week
have been full broadcasting tweets and
I've had about one or two up to 5% of
actually replying to people on Twitter
Twitter is the cocktail party of our
society and it's about listening and not
talking if you go look at my Twitter
account which is Gary Vee you will see
that when you hit all because the way
Twitter you landed you just see what I
broadcast but up there you can toggle
and say all you will see that 90% of my
tweets are responding to people I'm
searching wine or business terms and
jumping into conversations and now I've
gotten big enough that a lot of stuff
comes to me and I just answer I bring
value we are not bringing value enough
in our networks and so what you need to
be thinking about is how do you story
tell in the platforms that matter to
bring value to your actual consumer how
do you make a tweet that brings
awareness to your event but isn't
pushing your event and the
I named my new book Jab Jab Jab right
hook is because it symbolizes to me give
give give and then ask I basically want
to live a life of guilting people into
doing the things that I want them to do
and I mean that it's important to
understand
I truly believe and most comfortable
it's my own DNA that if I give first
that if I pay forward first I have a
dramatically better chance to convert
and when we market our events we are not
giving first we need to give them free
content we need to answer their
questions
we as organizers needs to jump on
Ustream or spreecast for an hour and
answer questions about it we need to
help promote the people that are our
event not just pay them to use their
equity to drive people to the event we
need to be events that build up
personalities because that's a way for
you to save dollars instead of paying
for personalities we need to understand
this very important statement I really
need you to leave with this every person
in this room and every event in this
room is a media company and if you don't
understand that you have no chance of
being relevant going forward this is a
very substantial statement and I want to
say it again both your events and you as
individuals are now thrusted into
competing as media companies and if you
are not putting out content and if you
are not engaging with the end consumer
you were going to have a very difficult
time to breakthrough in an extremely
noisy world and that's that and that's
what's happening and so I have clients
fortune 500 clients there they're
spending billions of dollars on
billboards right here's a classic
example of what how I think about this
when you guys leave this conference I
know a lot of people probably New
Yorkers but if you're not and if you
happen to drive especially outside of
the city do me a favor remember this
talk and think of this one point when
you're driving look at five people
driving by you right
just drive look at five people I've been
doing this at scale now for about six
months I'm gonna tell you a couple
things number one
Oprah is right it is dangerous out there
I've literally for the first time in 20
years I'm now driving with two hands
because let me tell you this 3/4 out of
every 5 people are actually looking at
their phone while they're driving right
so my friends billboards which sell on
impressions which when you used to drive
you might have saw people aren't looking
at billboards anymore they're not even
looking at the [ __ ] road anymore
there's a bus stop ad right by my office
I couldn't get my phone out quick enough
to take this picture there was a GI Joe
the movie the rock good-looking dude
diesel big poster right they probably
paid about $8,000 for it a lot of
traffic in New York City used in 1997 in
2003 you would have saw that you were
walking to the office you saw it every
single person I was walking the other
way all 12 people were doing this and so
they didn't see that and they didn't see
your banner ad and they deleted your
bulk email promoting your event and on
and on and on and so I implore you to
start taking these channels seriously
Instagram got 50 million users 50
million users in 1.6 years right and 15
months of a theme I mean 50 million
users in a snap right these platforms
vine 15 million users right in 90 days
we're at scale at the Internet ret scale
we're just starting
we're grossly under estimating it and
what we want to do is we want to shout
and push and tell people about our thing
and what we need to do is listen and
think and then convert that listening
which is what is I like to call consumer
insights a funny thing happens when you
really understand what people think
about your events or the events that
they want to go to right if you are not
searching the key terms in your business
on Twitter event what I did you know
those things at night where they go
hashtags of events you know competitive
events if you're not searching and
understanding the sentiment and the
feedback the authentic feedback that
they're giving not when you give them a
little thing at the end of the
conference and say how is it I
everybody's always over-indexing know
the way they really think on Facebook
and Twitter when they you know act like
themselves not through a form if you're
not understanding that feedback and if
you're not paying attention that
feedback you're missing out on so much
data of how to make your product and
service better and so that's what I
spend all my time on how do I story tell
in the actual year that it is in the way
that we actually do things how many
people here watch television don't
answer yet how many people here watch
television mainly on their time either
on-demand
DVR HP on the go outside of live sports
and Sunday night because it's got its
own little thing outside those things
how many people in this room don't lie
no half-ass hands watch TV on their time
raise your hand okay weird everybody how
many of you in 2013 have fast forwarded
every single commercial raise your hand
we heard almost everybody meanwhile the
clients I work with collectively are
gonna spend ninety billion dollars
trying to tell you a story that in 2006
you would have saw and heard and
understood and made a decision about
that you no longer consumed and even if
they're lucky to get the commercial to
air in your face how many people here
watch television with at least one other
electronic device a phone a laptop or an
iPad raise it good everybody to give it
to me to a phone and either a laptop or
an iPad raise your hands raise them high
raise them high
front row look back I just want you to
understand keep them up raise them high
we're talking about let's just let's
just quantify this my friends
eighty-five percent of this room watches
television with two other screens to
distract them so even if a commercial
comes to tell you to buy something you
know that when you're watching the
Bachelorette and you take out your phone
and you're like holy [ __ ] I can't
believe she did that you're not paying
attention to the actual commercial just
out of curiosity how many people here
watch television with three screens
phone laptop and iPad raise your hand
all right I'm going to need to talk to
the 11 of you you've got some issues
let's connect after this and it's gonna
get worse and worse and worse when the
Beatles had long hair that was a bad
thing that was rogue right everybody
thinks snapchats about sexting snapchat
about sexting is old white people
writing stories about snapchat snapchat
is a communication funnel that for those
nine seconds while you're holding it you
actually have to pay attention which is
why it's important and once it evolves
the way Facebook evolved and becomes
older there'll be an opportunity for you
can you figure out how to tell a story
in an 8-second picture with text over it
that disappears can you give them a
value proposition of why they should
come can you be smart enough in
marketing that know that snapchat works
that you can screen shoot it and if they
screen shoot it that gives them $10 off
at the door are you smart do you get it
because I promise you the people that
aren't smart that don't get it they get
put out of business and much better
business people and much better
organizations and much richer people
than you have been putting out of
business in the last 10 years because
they refuse to play like the year that
we're actually in don't be that person
don't let that happen I hope you have a
good day
[Applause]